I'm trying to get the slap by promotion
we need that slap fight the same Vibes
the slap fight gets into into what
you're doing the slap fight and then
when I was talking to the fight pass
guys they're like well what do you want
I'm like man I want the same kind of
marketing that gets Patty pemble it two
million Instagram followers every week
he gets it deleted he like gets his
Instagram deleted for saying something
and then the next week he has two
million followers the next week is three
million followers and he gets it deleted
again I'm like that's kind of marketing
I want it's crazy a lot of the slot bike
guys I met them at the pi and a lot of
them do Jiu Jitsu I met like both teams
and like oh man what's up Gordon I was
like Hey guys like I didn't know how you
know me but they're like oh man like I'm
a purple belt I did and I saw a lot
of like behind the scenes stuff with
them filming definitely interesting for
sure but if Jiu Jitsu can get that kind
of marketing that's all we need the UFC
invest like heavily into grappling which
I think they are now thankfully